what does he care I just was going to
promote uh something that we're going to
do next what is that with somebody from
our somebody's going to come in and make
a big announcement do we have to do that
right now uh we probably should do it at
seven because we have something at 7 30
we have something at 8 30. oh okay all
right all right I'll do that then all
right but at first I'm gonna take a
break
thanks for moving me along here I wasn't
moving you along I was actually sort of
pre-promoting something okay all right
thank you
[Music]
Gary doing some free promotions
I thought you'd be excited to promote it
I am I'm very excited I'm more excited
when you promote it though it's better I
like your pre-promotional listen I
listen if if I if you were there and I
sat there and I was the audience okay
and you cracked a joke and I went yeah
all right whatever isn't a promotion
something you do before the event yeah
so you can't pre-promote of course you
can
he's pre-promoting that wasn't actually
promotion it was pre-promotion and then
the promotion that's a promotion
you don't pre-promote you either promote
or you don't okay you did promotion you
didn't do pre-promotion I guess so yeah
I guess you're right coming up though
the promotion what you heard Gary do is
pre-promotion and a little later you'll
have the promotion free promotion and
then the actual promotion
is there going to be post promotion I
guess so yeah so if this is a
pre-promotion then promotion then the
event and then post promotion I learned
that it's cool that we have
pre-promotion I think we're the first
Radio Show in the country to get that
someone's really coming to make a big
announcement but why are you saying that
because it's pre-promotion
sorry Gary I should not have pointed
that out
[Music]
please